歡迎收看最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李兆華
今天台股的氣氛整個不一樣囉
上漲的加速高達1400多加
今天中場上漲了600多點
而且是越漲越高越漲越高
今天的凌晨大家都在等
等揮答的財報跟法說
當然我們也知道
歷年已經連續實際
法说会后会下跌
但是这一次有些事情看起来不一样
Varubin已经有部分交货 装机 测试
市场显然对整体AI股
又燃起了希望的火种
在这样的情况下
我们所谓的第二只脚
是不是已经打完了
正式要起功
站在一个预备线上呢
今天外资在现货市场也是买超的
而且空单是回补的
有很多的迹象都在暗示
好像行情快要正式启动
但是我们进场一定要注意安全
要了解产业的趋势
也要了解心态
所以来欢迎今天三位来宾了
第一位是K线之神
朱家宏 朱老师
朱老师上个礼拜来才在讲
第二只脚快要打好了
但今天的说法不同
第二只脚应该是打好了
新的目标价帮我们画出来了
今天台股有很多的公司创下历史新高
最引人注目的例如像大力光
好 整個光學是非常的熱喔
所以朱老師說
只要該族群有人創下歷史新高
有領頭羊
那我們進場選什麼呢
看高做低 幫您挑
中低價同族群形態已經打好的
現在去買最佳安全喔
好 第二位呢
是我們的產業趨勢專家
王建文 王博
王博一直都在幫CPU 光通訊送暖喔
從谷底送到聯亞也要創新高了
好 大立光也創歷史新高的情况下
还有哪一些
其实这个族群反弹的程度
比较参差不齐
尤其美股前一阵子
其实有下跌
所以今天王博独家帮我们找
在光通讯CPU这个领域里面
他觉得位阶算低
而且法人大户在做聚集的
以及刚刚讲到的
灰达的新机即将要装机量产了
所谓的800伏这件事情
在今天的盘面上也受到瞩目
BBU相关的广宝科
300块大关上去了
那谁会接着紧接着往上走呢等一下王博帮你选喔好第三位第一次來理財達人秀是新面孔但也是舊面孔喔就是理財達人秀首代IP創辦人
現在在普惠頭顧
擔任分析師的陳俞成
好俞成來了
剛剛跟他話家長非常的久
但他今天要強調一件事情喔
今天晚上
揮答的財報
會不會不一樣
連續實際喔
每次看完財報
不管講多好
都是往下殺
但是Vear Ruby提早已經交貨給大家了
這件事情帶動的叫做
PCB規格 全面拉好拉滿
等一下余晨文告訴大家
PCB現在走向一個叫無步化
好 到底誰受惠 誰受害
台廠的受惠名單
等一下一次告訴您喔
好 首先有請朱老師
你好
朱老師 這肯定句耶
對 對
好 第二角打完
沒錯
台股的新目標價
真的很振奋
不過今天很多上新高的股票
都幾千塊
可能大家覺得追不上
但沒有關係
今天幫我們挑的
都是中低價抵不起張股
那我記得上次有講
我們回來有個最重要的支撐
就是月線不要跌破
其實真正關鍵的是昨天
不是今天
因為昨天如果不拉的話
這個月線就不保了
那你昨天打個電話給我
我就要讓您跟明漢互換
对 昨天这一根最重要
因为它如果下去
你看我们盘中有下了五六百点
后来又拉了就
拉到月线
对 所以昨天这一根就透露出来说
这个月线是可以撑住的
它可以撑住
第二个 昨天这里
各位看回档一天两天三天四天五天
昨天是第五天就在这个横盘
它没有上去也没有下来
那今天就来决定了
它為什麼講今天確認
因為今天的收盤
把這五天全部都過了
就說一根紅K
吃了五根K線的高點
所以今天這根K線就很漂亮了
因為它收在相對高點
它沒有留什麼上限
那第二個量
今天站上五日均量
這個很重要
你看我們從這個地方
一路量一路鎖
我們都上禮拜也講
沒有量就沒辦法
所以我們為量試問
只要你看到量
能夠持續放大
它就會開始往上去挑戰
好 因為今天確認了
在底部來講
因為這是空頭嘛現在轉多頭嘛現在轉多頭因為這個已經過高所以这边是头头高我们讲了说一定要来一个第二只脚它就变多了
但第二只脚有好有坏嘛
那这个第二只脚就很强啊
因为它在月线上
现在的第二只脚
我们叫做N字底
所以用N字底来算目标价
可以到51,326
直接算给大家看了一下
这叫目标价
可能当然也要一段时间
或者遇到歷史高點
還會在這邊震盪
這個大家先做好心理準備
那整理好了以後
如果歷史高點過
其實到51326也沒有太遠
是啊
只有3000點
前面是4萬8
對 只有兩三千點
所以過那個歷史高點
應該目標價也可以
也容易的就大
我們現在的股票有很多
都是創高了
那只有一個
就是台積電還沒有創歷史高點
台積電在這邊算升盤要角
對 那我們上禮拜也講過
為什麼台積電現在看起來比較弱
但是它並沒有跌
它還在這個地方
那就是把空間讓出來
那這時候如果像我們剛才的大盤
要去公立時高點
這個台積電就會上來
它就會出來
所以台積電有台積電人
也就稍微的等一下了
它並沒有說走壞或什麼
因為我們上禮拜也講
台積電目前來說
它只要過了2445多頭就反轉
就完成了
那這個完成多頭
當然就會挑戰歷史高點
不過這邊的話
它也是代表揮打概念
所以今天全值有在指數上面
給予貢獻之外
還有創新高的刷一排
結果各位有沒有發現
創歷史高點的股票一摞框
所以大力光不要走
這裡有目標價
形態目標價
大家可能自己可以練習
我相信大家一看就看出来形态了
对不对
这就是一个圆湖底
我不敢说很简单
这个是圆湖底嘛
这个圆湖底可以到7035
其实大概还有700块
大概700块吧 710
那因为它还是多头
所以你既然已经报那么久了
那你就继续做
那空手的那就看这个空间
你要不要去做了
因为空间大概也算有限了
大概一层
大概還有一層的空間
好 那聯誼光也是創立高點
光學概念 今天好幾檔但是聯誼光的這個目標價已經快到了因為它的目標價是128.5這在周縣裡面去看周縣是中期嘛
周縣是一個N字底
所以周縣會到128.5
但是並不是說128.5到了就沒有了
不是這個意思
就是說它因為有個型態
它會往這個方向走
那走到了如果多頭不變
當然就繼續走
它還會繼續創新高
那光寶科目標價也過了
這個陽城也過了
陽城這一陣子也是一直漲一直漲
所以他的目標價也到了
那彩虹他因為沒有形態
那創意也是創歷史高點
對 創意上歷史新高
6100他的目標價是6900
接近7000啊
可以去用形態推估
大家都可以用形態去看
有的在日線 有的在周線
因為有的在日線上
你這樣看起來很亂
其實你回到周線就很清楚
它就有一個ABC突破
這個飄期的形態
全部都會出現
朱老師像光寶科
大家現在那麼注目它
過了那怎麼辦
過了就照多頭去做
回後買上漲
因為我們大盤才剛剛反轉
所以很多的股票在底部打底
可是我們打底
各位一定要去觀察
這個條件要做好
否則你太早進場
可能會被耗在裡面
比如說這個季線
还有压力 月线还没有做好
那你进去了
可能别的股票都涨
你的股票没涨
但是你要抱住了
如果你进去就要抱一抱
最重要我们刚刚有讲
你空头一定要打个底底高
一定要完成
那空头在反弹的时候
这个地方就会形成压力
所以这你会调到压力线
只要它回来底底高
那你就很简单了
上面这个压力 下面是支撑
这个中间怎么走你都不要管
因為各種走法
有的是預月線又回來
但是最後這個壓力要過
因為這個壓力一過
多頭就確認
一定要等到這個
但是有的很快
咚咚咚就過了
有的搞了一兩個月才過
但是不管它早晚過
我們都是以技術面去確認它
那如果你多頭確認
卻在季線下
那表示你這支股票
只能做短線
會遇到壓力
對 因為季線有壓
所以你如果遇到季線回來
你這個地方要賣一趟
所以我這裡有寫請你停
出去一趟
出去一趟如果回來
再來回後買上漲
對不對
如果都在月線季線上
這你四線多排
你也可以做長線
這邊波段就可能拉出來
可能這個會有一波兩波
因為這個叫出升段就開始
它可能會有主升段 末升段
所以底部這樣子都反轉
在中間你再看這裡有沒有大量
如果在打底的時候
都有錯有大量
都代表這支股票
有阻力在这里
已经事先布局了
他已经先买了
或者是800张1000张的大户
大家都可以去看
都可以找到资料
好 那我们来看一下
这个
刚刚已经讲说
有光绝股
大力光
对不对 郁金光 阳明光
对
就是有蛮多今天光学股
的表现非常强势
但是有的
有的创
有的还在底部打底
那我们可以看吧
领头羊都已经上去了
那这些同类的
是不是有好的这个股票的形态
或者底部
那我们就可以去介入了
好 我们来看一下
好 阳明光在今天
也是今天
因为这个地方有个压力嘛
对不对
那这个压力今天收盘就过了
那这一过
这也是可以把它当作个圆弧底
只是这个圆弧底的
右把柄打得比较久
就是它到压力没有过
如果这边过
就是一个标准的圆弧
对嘛 但没有过
那这个就是在右边打右把柄
那打右把柄今天过
均线也做好了
20均已经碰到这个60均
那这样子的话
它就有目标价了
因为圆湖嘛
这会到105.8
那以这个目标价来讲
再以这个底部的量来讲
这有量嘛
那是有机会去过97.8
因为97.8
大概就这一根量嘛
大量
我们这边很多量
好多天的量
所以再加上我們講
大戶也都在這裡佈局
所以這支股票是有機會
去到目標價
但是大家要切進去
還是要按照我們節目
每次跟大家講的
不要追高 回後買上漲
回後買上漲
而且如果它真的破線了
也要走 對
那這一支就是我們剛剛講
上了月線 季線有壓
所以它回來
今天打了第二支腳
這是第一支腳這是第二支角可是它上月線的時候過了前高所以它跟我們的大盤是一樣的先過前高 然後出第二隻腳
所以它今天是多頭確認
但是因為季線還沒上
所以有可能明天碰到季線
這裡又出一個黑K
但是大家如果要鎖它
最好是讓它上了季線
上來也許兩天三天
下一次都回後買上來
因為它這邊這個量也不小喔
上引線超級長要克服
還有一個就是
它要過季線應該這邊
還是會放量
它還會放量
所以我們等它拉回來
這邊連續過季線兩三天
放大量回來量縮
然後再勾
至少它有一個空間
80到100
這個空間真的過不去
你也不會賠錢
只是你大概就賺到這
過去你的獲利就會比較高
還有另外非光學族群的
其實散落在各領域
都有這種底部形態完成的
那這些就是符合
我們剛才教學的圖的
在底部打底的
有的是多頭完成的
有的上了月線還沒過季線
還有的也許過了季線
那這裡面大家就可以去看
其實這些股票
都是大家很熟悉的股票
因為在前面這個七月以前
都是很會髒
你看這個藍牙是不是
很會髒
很活潑
只是七月到八月就一直跌
可是现在它抵出来了
你看都涨停板了
我一直讲一个空头股票
如果跌到不管跌到哪里
你一出现涨停板
这个地方大概就不太容易再破
表示多方转强了
那我们不妨看看
有没有这些好股票
好CPU的重达KY
你看看这是不是很标准的
先上了月线会到季线
那季线有压
所以你这边就会回来
回来的观察就是月线不要跌破
那今天就确认了
对不对 今天是不是这个就过了
所以他多头确认
好给王国面子
我一直跟他讲
空头转多头
现在唯一的就是均线
这个月线还没有穿过季线
可是如果你下一次来看
月线就穿过
那这里就可以去挑战
是 这边也是大量高点
他都是空转多
多再往上去
那回来也一样
从高点就回到上次的低点
就回到上次的低点
所以這就是我們標準的
一個底部股票那這支股票在這裡就完成多頭了跟這個一样反弹 横盘 突破就完成多头那现在因为季线有压
也许你没有做回来了
我刚刚有讲嘛
你上季线再拉回来
那现在就拉回来了
所以今天这个叫做回后买上涨
那这个量就够了
它中间在跌的时候完全没有量
那这个代表什么意思
這個最大量一定是散戶買的
那就是散戶還抱在手上
還抱在手上
那會不會形成上漲的壓力
沒有 現在就等解套
其實很快了
這個已經沒有很遠了
它只要一完成多頭
它雖然有散戶還抱著
但是因為有主力 大戶都進來了
那它容易去解套
如果散戶稍微耐心一點
因為它已經轉多了
不许不要再去
那这支鼓钥大家
也许不一定看得懂
但是我给大家解释一下
这是空一定没问题吧
南亚
这一定是空头嘛
是
对不对
头头的地
不过它厉害是它在地线指
对它在地线撑住了
那你空头要再转强
一定要变多嘛
这个就是底底高来了
今天是底底高啊
那换句话讲
明天过了这个它就变多
是
那現在多空要對四
這是空 這是多
那就看誰厲害了
那如果這個多把230過
它就會大漲一波
就會漲這樣一段
漲一波
它就會漲一段
因為在技術分析有一個口訣
這叫空轉多
又過了空高
過了空的高點
這邊就會大漲
我存講技術沒有
因為基本面這些
都有專家在講
別擔心 第三段
對 技術面如果把230過
那這支股票就另外一個空間
因為我們講的那些幾千塊
都在創歷史高點
這個才幾百塊
所以當然還有空間可以去
可以去期待 還有空間期待
好 朱老師感覺出了
有一些考題
要後面兩位來賓來接招
可是整個型態看起來
其實高高低低
都有可以做的股票
所以心態已經完全是好轉的狀態
沒錯
非常謝謝朱老師好 朱老師每個禮拜三固定的嘉賓台股最慘破四萬點的那一天也是一個星期三從那一天一路呵護上來也看到打腳
應該算是確定完成了
希望所有的產業
能夠在這樣的形態上面
好好的往上發展
今天創新高的公司蠻多的
而有創新高的領域下面
都還有中低價形態做好的
以及散布在各AI科技股裡面
剛剛朱老師點名了相當多檔
大家不妨回家看一下
因為有的是即將多空對峙
交戰完成後有可能走一大波的
希望提供給您選古的參考
廣告回來王博要上場了
王博也是一路從CPU
在加護病房呵護到連亞都要創高了
那到底現在CPU因為反彈的幅度
稱之不齊
法人大戶有沒有在看一些地位接的
答案是有
那800不要量產了
今天BBU也是盤面的亮點
除了光寶科
誰是下一檔光寶科
等一下王博來揭曉
今天台股真的是光通閃閃的
非常亮眼的一天
但是能不能延續呢
我们还是会觉得
如果早一点进场布局的
创新高的有恭喜各位
但如果现在手上报的股票
还在比较低位阶的
我们就来听听看
王博不一定是要送暖
但是要送信心了
像CPU其实看高做低
还蛮多谈的没有非常高的
再来800伏創量产
其實BBU之前的漲勢也都不太連貫
可是光寶科真的給了大家希望
誰會是下檔光寶科
其實今天的體感溫度蠻高的
我記得7月29號
我還跟朱老師在這一邊
冷收收的
還提醒大家說要趕快把握機會
可是大家想一想才一個月
才一個月
然後你看到很多的股票就這樣上來
之前可能在等解套
現在有很多的股票已經開始
開始在數鈔票
所以我的想法說
如果大家再往接下來的行情看
9月底有
9月有季底作帐
9月底
然后第四季常常都是涨多跌少
然后延续到圆月行情
搞不好
搞不好这就是
跌下来之后
先蹲后跳
搞不好大家最好的机会
但是我们还是要看一下
到底有哪些什么
有哪些已经表态了
表态出来之后有哪些股票
我们可以把它掌握起来
那当然
当然现在市场最大的几个讯息
一个是华许
華許要在那個接生後要演講
可是我之前往往看那個華許
有講過一段話
他說
升息不是唯一的解法
所以我們就靜觀其面看他要講什麼
另外就是輝達 輝達財報
說輝達財報之後
現在趕快什麼
趕快推出那個Vera Rubin
來幫他打打氣你知道嗎
所以我的看法說
如果我們接下來要延續
那個季縣這一邊
開始要往上攻的行情
我們還是用產業面的角度來看
那當然怎麼樣
輝達出來說了
交換器要開始放量
然後怎樣
他也跟你講了
接下來VR之後
Virabra之後
那當然什麼
AI的電力大戰要開打
所以我覺得這兩個主題
一個BBUHVDC
還有一個CPU
我們今天就來幫大家追蹤
那當然其實如果我們看台積電
台積電之前張小強也講了
所謂的Coup就是接下來的關鍵字
所以我個人認為
其實這個都是大家要注意的
那當然很多的股票
很多的股票慢慢上來了
特別我們如果從美國的股市來講
這一次台股比較強
對
台灣的那個細光子
CPU概率比較強
平行而論
因為之前這些股票
衝上去的時候是他們在貸
然後貸了一大段之後
結果這些股票在跌
這些股票跌的時候
反而我們的什麼
我們的老CPU跟新CPU
包含像所謂聯亞
跟所謂大力光衝上去
但是要提醒大家
包含像Vertiv跟BE
這個是跟店有關係的
這個BE大家要特別留意
裴洛西不是買了BE嗎
還買了選擇權
國會的女股神
美國國會的女股神
她買BE啦
所以我覺得說
其實她可能也是看好電
所以我認為啦
我認為其實這個都是
我們接下來在台股裡面要去思考
要去面對佈局的啦
那當然CPU我講很多了
我們再來看一下
輝達的所謂電力大戰要開打
以前怎麼樣
以前那個相關的那個電的
那個相關的組件
全部都塞在
所謂的AI機櫃裡面
但問題來啦
如果你現在把所有東西塞進去的話
會產生一個狀況
塞不進去還有散熱的問題
所以現在他就把電力的機櫃
把它給獨立出來
以前叫塞卡
現在大家把它叫成POWER REC
所以我認為如果說
接下來大家考量到所謂的AI的發展
然後還要一個穩定高品質的電的話
這個難怪啦難怪台灣的這些廠商受賄所以這是輝達的規劃然後這個是我們的三本柱大電是 當然我們都說大電現在的漲勢是落後公寶科
但是今天也是有小表現了
平常請講 因為之前在漲的時候他還帶
然後後來跌下來的時候
他好像還在慢慢的從低檔低位階拉上來
我們之前有送軟過 他有小漲上來
至少低點沒有破 那就有看他的規劃
公司派其實基本上還是滿正面
倒是我們之前
也是一直一直送暖的光寶科
嚇一跳 真的嚇一跳
沒想到最近強成這個樣子
因為看到快到300
想說300關卡嘛
照樣給他衝過去
不要說300
那時候100多 200的時候
大家都想說這個股票不會動
股性太差 法說會變法會
那時候大家都很對他很沒責
可是後來就是一大段
大力光也是我們一直非常看好的
王伯曾經也在大力光
修正的時候送暖鍋
從那個時候到今天創新高
已經漲了59個百分點
聯亞也是這一波零化音的大贏家
漲了三成
哇 所以聯亞已經
今天漲得快要回新高了
看起來這個應該不是什麼問題
雙箭頭啦 雙箭頭啦
其實那個時候
我們在講大力光的時候說
其實它切入所謂CPU
那特別FAU這一段
我們想說現在市場上就是一成
它可以做到四成
那時候我們討論說
因為它根本就還沒有貢獻
其實今天就算重返農業創高
還是沒有貢獻
還沒有量成
但問題來
問題來就是說
其實這就是一個題材
那當然如果說
接下來輝達台積電
要所謂加速的光進同退
那當然什麼
當然它的技術是領先的
所以大家就想說
為什麼大力光最近的動作
越來越大
那當然越來越大的話
當然可能胸有成竹
因為它列地
我想今天這個對它注意很大
對
所以我覺得就沿著五日線操作
當然如果是那個朱老師的話
他可能會提醒你
就是說這種股票你不要去放空
你就順勢操作
然後回後買上漲
回後買上漲
其實有時候我們也是
跟在朱老師旁邊學一些技術分析
兩家投信都非常的支持
其實有時候投信會買龍頭
會買那個領頭羊
所以我接下來
接下來這是所謂的新CPU部分
那老CPU部分其實那個漲跌更分歧
新CPU其實有一檔帶一檔
那個大立光上去那個浴晶光就上去但是老CPU就有點分歧等一下我們來看有沒有比較可以值得注意的然後看高做低的那當然這個是我們在看的兩個箭頭先把它抓出來
兩個箭頭抓出來之後
我們就要看籌碼
然後看高做低
比較有趣的
其實我們看
這個都有千張大戶在增加持股
所以平行而論
投信之前棄手CPU
投信回來之後
其實你可以發覺說
不管是外資也好
或者是400張大戶
千張大戶
我的確有在琢磨
那當然我的看法就是說
那這個趕長
那當然什麼
弟弟妹妹我們也要注意
那個可可姐姐衝快一點沒關係
弟弟妹妹後面也要上
但是這一次我們沒有把光盛放上來
為什麼
其實光盛不錯
你不講我還沒注意到
我之前送軟送到覺得說
光盛的股性好難送
前兩天也有送一根帳停辦
對
那所以我們以前的領頭羊是光盛
後來我就說應該我們是要看聯亞
聯亞 大力光
那當然如果聯亞上去
波羅威 環境光
那當然光深也會上去
所以大家也可以注意
注意說股性能不能夠變好
這比較重要
那有時候股性變好
那當然它的股價會比較活潑
好 今天來送暖是環宇KY
雖然今天也是漲停板
但是可以看得出來
很明顯位階反彈的沒有很高
對 因為你看
這邊還是一個均線的糾結區
它沒有說像這樣直接衝上去
我認為其實它有一個優勢就是美國製造
另外就是800G的PD
它是市占全球第一
那當然前五月的營收年增
百分之45.74%
前七月的營收年增百分之45.74%
那當然我認為接下來當然我們要看
數字會不會一直進來
那如果數字進來的話
因為這也是今年的腰股之一嘛
就是讓它能夠怎麼
能夠再看能不能再腰起來
如果能夠再腰起來
其實很多股票就一檔一檔上來
那當然剛才像那個重達KY
說這個重頭科也是突然跳上來
嚇一跳
所以KY股大家可能也可以開始留意
那一樣先區間
先區間大家就把這個區間記起來
包含像7月16號的高點
還有那個8月25號的低點
先區間一段一段做
看能不能越站越穩
這一檔說真的數字還沒有進來
好 就是有點在幫我們做一些延伸
對不對 對 延伸
因為現在新舊CPU都有話題
對對對
那因為上半年EPS-2.85
有点多耶
对 不大好看
但是问题啦问题是说因为它是做设备那接下来当时要提醒大家说它那个设備的出貨量會不會提高然後營收獲率會不會拉上來它還在黏線啊
很慘很慘
跌慘了 225-1287
其實它之前也曾經
因為那個所謂CPU的題材
也拉過一段
但是你看這樣跌下來
也都不客氣的啦
現在高票一年起來
也是狠狠
然後下來也狠
那我注意到這檔股票是因為
它要參加下個月的
國際半導體展
然後它要展示什麼
展示包含像LAN還有FAU的光彩檢
因為它本身就是所謂的設備廠
還有PIC晶片的測試設備
那另外它是針對1.6T 3.2T
推出主動是對位矽光紙藕光貼合機
所以沒有辦法
如果說我們在看那個發展的過程當中
我們當然很期待說
它的營收獲利能夠馬上進來
如果說營收獲利沒有辦法馬上進來的話
它至少有一個所謂設備的題材的話
你就放到口袋裡面
然後等到它數字出來
甚至說我們看到什麼
投信大戶開始進來的時候
因為有時候春江水奶壓先知
我們可能划得比較慢一點
但是儲利大戶還有
投信可能快一點
那你就可以留意
那當然這檔股票就提供給大家
因為位階低
位階低也曾經標過
對 而且大家那時候在看
也不知道它在標什麼
但是它有CPO題材
而且設備廠商照理來說
如果有這樣韌列進來
要轉虧為營不會太難
對 很快很快
那接下來就是我們剛才提到
因為以前都塞在那個
AI的機櫃裡面
現在把它獨立出來
有一個所謂的電力櫃
那如果是電力櫃
還有包含像所謂800VDC的
那個相關的題材的話
那當然我們會怎麼
HVDC BBU一個組合
然後公立半導體一個組合
一個所謂的相關的內容
那我們就來看有什麼注意
都有領頭羊
重點是都有領頭羊
HVDC BBU的領頭羊是光寶科
對 然後呢
之前的公立半導體
是所謂的那個什麼
強茂台辦
今天都漲停耶
但是之前跌下來速度也很快
對 所以我認為
我認為我們就來看有沒有機會
看起來怎麼樣
看起來數字都還不錯
慢慢進來了
然後外資跟投信也有琢磨
所以這就是我們必須想說
是不是說有的股票衝上來之後
包含像順打
順打接拉漲
漲停辦
是不是一個一個帶一個
那這種股票如果在低檔低位階
我們就可以注意
好 整體都是跟電有相關的
這絕對是必備的
其實還有很多
為什麼我說這是一個set
這個是一個set
其實還有很多
大家可以自己做功課
也許我們沒有列進去
也許你的股票還沒有動
那你就先把它列進去
然後去檢視一下
有沒有發動的那個機會
對 所以我覺得這個族群
其實滿大
所以有時候
當族群性出來的時候
那個助長的力量會更大
會更大
那當然之前我們講光寶科
之前其實在這邊講很多次
我們就沒有一一列出來
但現在它已經不需要你奉暖
其實那個時候
那個有時候
因为我们在选股的过程当中
你知道其实来那个理财团秀
我们都要很认真
都要费尽心力
那头发越来越少
然后就想说找一些好股票
然后那时候真的找不到一些
比较活泼的股票的时候
我就常常把光宝科拿出来讲
挡一下是不是
挡一下挡一下
没想到后来挡成标股啊
对不对
这个也是天道酬勤
挡成标股了
我们就要换下一档光宝科咯
一样啦一样就
就股价就是顺势操作了
而且比较特别的是
投信最近為什麼在這個位置只買
你看這邊賣到什麼樣的程度
就開始買了
所以這檔股票大家還是可以留意
我覺得光寶科應該
延均線操作
對 後世可期
那這檔股票其實之前我們講過
新勝利
衝上來差一點過高
差一點過高
那這個就是注意嘛 對不對
那個朱老師講的回後買上漲
他有沒有回 他有回
那如果回後買上漲
成交量又出來的話
而且大戶的持股又是什麼
不離不棄
明顯增加
對 那我覺得新勝利就有機會
而且我上次在講新勝利
我是拿它跟順達
對
因為這兩檔很活潑
然後新勝利其實上半年獲利是高於順達
然後現在的新勝利跟順達的股價差了快100塊
所以我認為今天順達拉上去
然後是不是說新勝利也有機會勾上
但是如果就形態來講
順達的位階是比較低
因為新勝利這一波有先拉動
對 先拉動一段
那我覺得大家可以留意
那另外就是說如果要從
公率半導體公立原件
因為看到強茂台辦都漲
順德另外一檔順德今天也拉上去
那我覺得因為這檔股票其實有點悶
還在黏啊
對 那我之前有提醒過
因為大戶的持股是沒有鬆動的
然後他的主要的大股東就是國劇
就是國劇集團 同心店 台美
然後要漲價15%
所以我的看法是說
那不如怎麼樣 守租待吐
這種股票也可以留意好 都是幫我們找相對像上次我還印象很深跟順達比以獲利來說但是因為漲了一段回後買上漲大戶再增加貿達就等他表態吧
就等他表態啦
我覺得就良性輪動的過程當中
就是火種一個一個
把它點燃上來
我覺得目前看來
接下來的行情應該滿有細的
好 滿有細的
非常謝謝王博
謝謝趙老師
好 王博的結論滿有細的
但是當然要立足在
我們看到有領頭羊的情況下
CPU真的叫做一路送暖送到聯亞大力光
都已經在歷史新高的附近了
大力光是創高了
但還有接下來有一些CPU
如果前張大貨或是法人的籌碼持續進駐
相信後面還很有表現的空間
跟地利相關的BBU功率半導體等等的
這個也是未來一定標配
一定要用到要升級要漲價的
那廣寶科上去了剛剛也跟大家分享了
還有一些低位階相關的族群獲利表現都不錯的
給您參考喔
好廣告回來我們的余程
回娘家了
于晨回来呢
他过去钻研的
就是整体的PCB的领域
接下来所谓的VR-Rubin
已经在所谓的测试装机了
里面有一句话叫做
PCB的规格
拉到最满
而且可能要无部话
等一下于晨独家来告诉您
这样的一句话
后面代表的是台厂的商机
好 当年于晨
是跟趙华一起創辦理財達人秀的
手帶的IP製作人就是陳余辰
後來他離開我了
跑去考分析師
考到分析師了
現在很厲害
專研的是PCB的領域
讓我們來歡迎余辰回來
趙华姐好
好 我可以很簡單的講一下
余辰曾經跟我們是作戰的夥伴
對不對
也有曾經大吼大叫
流過眼淚的那一種
我們一起創業
要講出來
對 結果呢
他跟我的好姐妹婉婷跑了
他去了統一頭顧研究PCB
最後呢
也從婉婷那兒跑了
因為去了老王跟普惠頭顧
喜歡的是普男
好 所以我們跟婉婷的感情
就變得更好了
對
那余辰當然就是專研PCB
非常讚
我剛才已經先看過你的資料了
今天要來很獨家的講一件事情
坊間恐怕還沒有什麼人討論
當然就是VR Rubin他出貨
重點在揮答這一次晚上
會不會一反前十季
講完之後不要再疊了
還有PCB的規格拉滿有一句話叫無步化有一個新的材料你已經研究好了全系列你幫我們搭配了會漲到台場的誰有沒有哪一些台場要留意的
好 那先從NVIDIA
這一次的表現來看
因為過去大家對於NVIDIA
都會有點擔心
就好像股價都漲在前面
然後財報過後呢
就變法會嘛
因為現在你看台股
這幾天法會也很多
那NVIDIA這一次
會不會變成法會
其實我覺得
這次可能有一些不一樣
那原因是因為這次的NVIDIA
在股價前一陣子這幾天
已經跌過了
對 所以我覺得這次
可能會稍微有一些扭轉
然後再來就是說
NVIDIA的氣氛也慢慢在改善
因為大家知道說
它的財報應該表現
不會有什麼太大問題
對啊 應該很好吧
絕對好 絕對好
那重點是在於說
接下來第四季
那因為市場上會期待NVIDIA
在展望的部分
去交出千億美元的營收
那因為它第三季已經900多億了
所以你要挑戰千億美元
有沒有可能
我覺得還是有可能的
因為這個出來了嘛
這個就是Valrubin
Valrubin
開始來了嘛
給微軟了也給紅海了
對陸陸續續開始交貨了
那最近其實我們從供應鏈
也在聽說就是很多的組裝廠
都在搶說第一個要出Valrubin
所以從Valrubin的需求來看的話
應該沒什麼太大問題
所以我覺得在NVIDIA的展望上面
應該會表現不錯
好 等於之前大家一直很擔心
Veia Rubin出貨
會不會有地顏什麼的
可是他就是在財報公布前宣告
順利
對不對
現在順利要量產
對 所以而且從這個Veia Rubin
順利量產之後呢
大家就會有個氣氛
什麼氣氛
會開始想說
下一代
下一代它會變成什麼樣子
因為現在已經
2026年下半年了
對
那接下來2027年下半年
就是它新一代
下一代的規格要推出了
那所以說現在市場上
其實也不是在討論
Veia Rubin的量產
這麼喜新研究
已經沒有在討論這個
大家都在討論
新的Vera Rubin
Rubin Ultra的規格
這Ultra的規格到底是怎樣
所以大家就會開始去翻
但你可以看到像
剛剛王博講的像800VDC
還有像這個CPU題材
好像最近這些新的東西
又全部活過來
原因就是因為現在市場上
開始去期待說
Rubin Ultra能夠帶來
我們一些新的驚喜
那這些新的規格裡面
有哪些東西
我們從這個新的這個
研報這Semi Analysis的報告裡面
他就告訴我們一個關鍵字
他說這個關鍵字
PTFE
PTFE要來了那這個PTFE你看他說NVIDIA他說計畫在Rubin Ultra的NV Switch這Switch版裡面他要使用PTFE材料這一家廠商
這家演奏機構
Semi-Anercy
最近含水會結動
含水會結動之前有掃過記憶體
他也打過光通訊
但他現在是支持這個PTFE的嗎
對 應該說
這個應該說PTFE這件事情
傳言很久了
然後被他這麼一講
現在市場上的這個
聯想又開得起來
所以大家開始講
找這關鍵字
PTFE到底是什麼東西
沒有 我們先去找誰受惠好了
他就開始去找
就一直瘋狂亂找
就是說台廠裡面
有PTFE是誰
可是他寫無部
所以看起來等一下
有點部的事情
會有一些聯想
重點就是在於說
這張圖它是台虹官網的截圖
台虹的官網 最近的標股
台虹官網它就告訴你說
它現在用的是PTFE型的CCO
它有在做這件事情
然後它是用無波纖的設計
來去做這件事情
你可以看到
台虹官網它揭露的這個疊構
就是說它的整個材料的
疊起來的結構
就是說它用這個PTFE
就上下兩層就像夾三明治一樣
直接用PTFE就夾兩個副銅上面
就可以來當作是CCL
那大家有沒有發現
好像少了什麼東西
它取代的就是中間這個波纖層
因為過去CCL
它中間就是用波纖層
來去做核心
可是台虹他告訴你說
他有辦法直接用PTFE
來去做核心
然後疊了腹酮之後
就變成CCO基板
那我們就要來想說
這到底合不合理
有沒有可能
好 先想有沒有可能是不是
所以我們要去來研究一下說
PTFE到底是什麼東西
那PTFE它的化學名字
不用記了就是聚四伏乙烯
好 你自己記就好了
對 可是大家在生活中
都常常在接觸這個材質
其實這個聚四伏乙烯
它就是不沾過材料
因為四伏乙烯它有一個非常強大的特性
就是說它的摩擦力非常小
所以我們在把它用在電子材料上面
有兩個很重要的係數
就是這個DK跟DF
我們之前在講說銅箔基板最重要的
就是這兩個數字
因為你DK跟DF越小
就表示說訊號在上面跑得越順暢
那這個阻礦越小 訊號越低
對於訊號的完整性當然就越棒
所以你要去做銅箔接著上面
會稍微困難一些些
你表面要做改質
這是一個困難點 第一個
再來就是說到後段的時候
假設你全部解決了
送到後段
因為PTFE這件事情
這個材料它比較偏軟
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕